&gt;&gt; We looked at solving linear equations graphically. We looked at the
intersection of two lines. And we know that the values of the coordinates, of
those points of intersection, would satisfy, either equation passing through
that point. So we're considering, the x intercepts, of our lovely parabola, that
we now have two equivelent equations for. What lines do we need to think about
intersecting, at either one of these points? I'll give you a hint, that it's the
same two equations at each point. And if you decide that this parabola is one of
the lines that you should use, then it doesn't matter if you write the equation
in this form, or in this form. Fill in the rest of these two equations right
here, that we are interested in.